there's another biology point that I
think is SAR and close to that one that
you brought up originally which is we as
humans have a proclivity to like our
Hardware basically wants to treat social
consensus as truth so when you hear the
same thing from a bunch of people your
brain Hardware is automatically like oh
that's what's correct if everybody
agrees I don't want to be out of Step
then that's truth and I'm on board with
it cuz I don't want to be ostracized for
my little tribe and that's not a
particularly effective way to like
understand truth and it takes work to
swim up upstream or to stand apart from
a crowd especially when people are
really vehement about it but knowing
that that's your tendency I think makes
it a little bit easier to battle that
and when you hear everybody saying the
same thing you should actually probably
start with a hypothesis like somewhere
far away from wherever they
are all right guys bang bang I've got
Eric here Eric is uh book number two as
many of you know he wrote the uh
bestselling book with uh naval's ideas
now he's back with the anthology of
balage
a guide to technology truth and building
the future it's fantastic I've read the
whole thing twice got my highlights I
did did all my work Eric you know I I
actually uh enjoyed it um I F let's just
talk about some of bl's ideas and and
kind of what maybe you took away from
them I think would be interesting as
well uh one of the first ones is only
trust as scientific truth what can be
independently verified which seems to be
a Hot Topic over the last three or four
years I like that one man and so I'm I'm
glad to be here talking to you about
this because I think these are like I
think this is the whe the middle of your
wheelhouse right like all your
overlapping Circles of like media
crypto like teele technology
acceleration like it's all in here and I
feel like I knew you'd be excited about
it so I'm glad we get to dive in um the
whole middle section on truth I think
is gonna be nobody's favorite but I
actually maybe think it's like the most
important like it's so important and we
all spend so much time on the social
media
like basically believing what we read
whether we like it or not like just the
algorithm just feeding you stuff and
there's been a lot of like last few
years of like trust the science do do
this do that and people are like losing
track of what science really is and I
think biology puts it I I have rarely
heard it put better um and I think that
quote like belongs up there with with
Fineman right it's like it has to be
independently verified and what he says
you know he worked in Academia for a
long time like guys got a PhD um and
he's like just because it's a peer
reviewed paper from an academic
institution like does not mean it is
science does not mean it is
independently verifiable does not mean
the results will replicate and doesn't
mean that we should be like changing our
lives or governing the country or
changing our habits even based on this
one paper and especially when you dive
in and you see the incentives behind
who's fun some of the research and what
institution actually comes out of so
like let's get back to the the
intellectually honest roots of science
which is like a bunch of people just
trying to figure out what's true like
running experiments that can that work
the same time every time this this
expansion of like treating everything
with the scientific method and the
scientific like the apparatus of
scientific method instead of the true
intellectual riger and I think that's
like very bad for society most people
don't have the discernment to tell the
difference between the appearance of
Science and the fundamental truth of one
intellectually honest truth that a bunch
of people have verified and is true
every time regardless yeah I think it's
a great point where
um people are being told something is
true because it gets a label almost
right and I always go back to like the
internet has in some ways uh reduced our
critical thinking as much as it's given
us a plethora of information like done
all this stuff like now you just like oh
it's on the internet it must be true
uh whereas like you know I don't know
thousands of years ago hundreds of years
ago like if somebody told you something
like you kind of had to figure out
because you actually do it at home right
it was like they passed it on by word um
so maybe it's actually not this new idea
it's just like a return back to the way
the world used to work I don't know I
mean maybe there was a period where like
the cost to write something down was so
high that you were more selective with
what you wrote down but I imagine I mean
I would like to think we as a society
are more correct about some of these
fundamental truths than we have been
ever in our history but there's a lot
that we believe today that is still
going to be wrong and obviously wrong to
Future generations to come but yeah the
internet just gave absolutely everybody
a microphone and like when you really
get to see everybody's inner thoughts uh
sort of treated like with equal weight
and truth that's when it's like oh maybe
maybe not everybody's right about
everything like there's a lot of people
that are just wrong about some
stuff and it it shouldn't be like
shouldn't be socially unacceptable to
say that especially when they're saying
like this is a truth with a capital T
when
it's objectively provable that it's not
um and the the politization of Science
and scientific truth or the tribalism of
it is is so bizarre and so damaging like
it really would behoove us to just
all concentrate on the truth so uh my
dad used to always tell me whenever I'd
ask him you know how do people believe
something or like why is this happening
or whatever one of his favorite kind of
go-to comments was think of the average
voter and remember about half of the
people are dumber than
that right and he was like by the way
like like if you're on the left you
think that of the right if you're on the
right you think that of the left if you
think you know if you're an Academia you
think that of Everyday People if you're
Everyday People you think that of
Academia like there's no somebody is
actually smarter or better or whatever
it's just like that is how we arrive at
some of these situations is like yeah
actually there's a distribution of
critical thinking intelligence and uh
you know other skills that might be
helpful in figuring some of it out and
and when you there's another biology
point that I think is simpler and close
to that one that you brought up
originally which is we as humans have a
proclivity to like our Hardware
basically wants treat social consensus
as truth so when you hear the same thing
from a bunch of people you're you're
brain Hardware is automatically like oh
that's what's correct if everybody
agrees I don't want to be out of Step
then that's truth and I'm on board with
it because I don't want to be ostracized
for my little tribe
and that's not a particularly effective
way to like understand truth um and
it takes work to swim upstream or to
stand apart from a crowd especially when
people are really vehement about it but
knowing that that's your tendency I
think makes it a little bit easier to
battle that and when you hear everybody
saying the same thing especially to your
point it's people who are likely to be
average or below average in like actual
information and critical thinking skills
then you should actually probably start
with a hypothesis like somewhere far
away from wherever they
are there's another uh quote many of our
leaders today are selected for
legitimacy but not for competence which
kind of plays into this to some degree
right where it's like okay do we trust
the social consensus but then also do we
trust like maybe the leadership and so
how do you think about that of like
legitimacy versus competence in
positions of leadership which then get
some degree of authority over groups of
people yeah I thought that was a very
interesting distinction I think B's got
a gift for these like creating uh
categorizations and like divisions
separating Concepts that seem that most
of us treat as conflated and I think
legitimacy and competency is a good one
you know as a tech guy and sort of a
West coaster he would say like you know
Founders are selected for legitimacy
Andy right they built they they
basically acred vote by vote customer by
customer their company their position
they built their empire around them they
didn't just get voted into being in
control of Facebook or apple or Amazon
right um whereas you the mayor of New
York didn't have to build New York
around him he just sort of want a
popularity contest to assume control and
the those are very different skills the
skill
of appearing as though you will do a
good job at this or building a consensus
amongst a group of people or just
getting the approval of 51% of a mob of
humans that's not the same skill set
that it takes to build New York in the
first place um and if you see like read
a biography of a founder and then read a
biography of Robert Moses who like is
one of the Builders of New York and then
look at who the mayor of New York is or
who the mayors of New York are and it's
very interesting to see the different
personality types and the different
hurdles that they had to overcome and
the different sort
of talents or perspectives that they
bring um and it's an interesting
question you know who the founding
fathers were um and our early presidents
and what they did compared to like what
our presidents do now different people
different skill sets different
challenges different roots to the
position um and B's point is is you know
learn to separate learn to see who's who
and choose leaders who are competent not
just have the appearance of legitimacy
um yeah I think like a good example is
vitalic in the crypto space right
like nobody just we didn't have an
electoral college like primary process
to get falic like he has earned his
position and I think continues to earn
it through just good stewardship and
intellectual honesty and building trust
and serving the community that supports
him um and I think it's a
fascinating way to look at the world and
important to remember and you especially
as you make your own choices like try to
be competent not just legitimate maybe
especially in the in the social media
world like for kids that want to grow up
and be influencers be creators um that's
something that is a little bit more like
about appearance than competence um it's
a meritocracy like don't get me wrong
and it's not an easy path and it's hard
work but it rewards the appearance of
competence not necessarily the
underlying competence and that
underlying competence will get you much
farther for much longer and and be
better for all the people around you it
it reminds me of uh I think Palmer lucky
recently gave an interview and they
asked him about like you know chasing
dreams and he was like no kids should
not chase their dreams and of course you
know everyone's like oh my God like
that's so bombastic why and he's like
because their dream is to literally be a
YouTuber like we should give kids better
dreams and then Chase those and like you
know there's a balance right I don't
know I got kids like you want them to
kind of Chase the things that they're
excited about but also you're like ah
maybe yeah yeah maybe we can influence
you to like do things that are more uh
material to the world or or kind of have
a bigger impact than just um you know
kind of go to the easy things that that
are right in front of your face yeah I
mean we're mimic so the things that we
watch people do we tend to our first
order reaction is like oh well I want to
be that like if you listen to a lot of
podcast you want to be a podcaster um
it's so funny to like watch people go to
Tony Robbins courses and he like fires
them all up and like but then they just
want to be Tony Robbins so they become
life coaches instead of like whatever
they actually wanted to be before they
walked in and saw this incredibly
powerful example of a life happy like
powerful life coach this CU they want to
be Tony Robbins not their own version of
themselves um but yeah I think Palmer
luies was a great uh that was a great
little bit he's like kids used to want
to be astronauts hell yeah go be an
astronaut you know you have to be a Navy
SEAL with a PhD with like perfect powers
of stoicism and like scci broad
scientific capability and chosen from
millions of applicants to represent your
country on the frontiers of technology
and be a hero and risk your life yeah
that's a great
dream oh you want to to be like a twitch
streamer like the shirtless the
shirtless twitch streamer who like
swears a lot like that's a yeah that's a
shitty dream and you should like do
better yeah I I mean look there's a lot
of kids who had their dreams shattered
in listening to Palmer but yeah that is
true um speaking of uh maybe kind of how
to influence uh some of what children
but also adults think of there's another
quote in the book um code is how
machines know what to do media is how
humans know what to do and I thought it
was just a perfect way to again kind of
describe this idea how did you think
about that this episode is brought to
you by Aron they are a brand new startup
led by a number of Silicon Valley
Legends who just raised $81 million to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanometer
silicon chip technology these aircooled
singlephase and dual phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency they've Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a r a d ne.com go check
them out at idine.com today yeah there's
a lot of
um similar ideas in there that you know
the idea of aics is is really um really
important and really powerful there's a
great book by Luke Burgess called
um he oddly seems to really rail against
bology online but whatever um the the
concept of mics if you haven't come
across it before it's basically like we
learn by mimicking other people um it it
goes back to this kind of like when you
spend a lot of time watching podcasts
you want to become a podcaster um we
learn how to walk by watching our
parents walk we learn how to speak by
listening to other people speak um and
it goes much deeper than that those are
just the obvious examples so when you
see a bunch of people like railing
against or scapegoating somebody you
tend to people tend to join that mob for
psychological and physical safety um and
the
media written large all of these things
that we become you know I think
somewhere else in the book he says like
you know if you could get the
nutritional facts on everything that
you're consuming if you could see how
many times different concepts different
words like pass into your eyes and ears
that literally would determine like what
you believe and what you are and it
would show you
how maybe how nutritious your inputs
were um so if you're
watching you know these brilliant people
like I'm you know this the poor
Charlie's Almanac just came out and like
Charlie Munger is a hero to me like I
just I picked up that his book off my
book dad's bookshelf at like 21 and it
changed my life and I'm like man the
more time I spend in the company of
Munger the better of a person I'm going
to be the more time I spend on the
Twitter or some sort of attention
mongering
like extreme
creators maybe the worst of a person I'm
going to be at least farther from who my
idealized version of myself according to
like my values and my principles um so
there's there's the sense of media makes
us who we are and tells us what to do
that we can choose that media it's also
that if you just sort of passively pay
attention to whatever the media decides
to put in front of you like whatever the
headlines of the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal The Washington Post are
that's someone
else putting their agenda sort of in
your mind and in your brain and that
always happens to some extent like
whether you know if you listen to every
P podcast like you're going to focus on
the things that pomp wants you to listen
to and pay attention to and you're just
placing trust in pomp to do that and I
think that's
increasingly actually a good way to go
through life like somebody who's
listened to 50 hours of you 100 hours of
you has a good sense of who you are and
what you're interested in and what your
values are and they trust you to put
good people in front of them that are
interesting that are valuable that are
constructive and it's just a little
harder to understand the motives of a
larger media organization that has
hundreds of reporters and editors and
you're not sure who they are you're not
sure what the ties are and there's a
whole history of this kind of very overt
media manipulation um it was an amazing
book by Ashley rensburg uh called the gy
lady winked it's about the history of
the New York Times and I think we're now
on like our
sixth generation of male descendants
named Arthur solsberg who are editor-in
chief and basically sole control of this
thing that's like one of the most
valuable media properties on the planet
planet and there's a lot of interesting
backstories about mistakes that were
made sometimes in error um that change
the course of world history but
sometimes overtly and potentially
maliciously they change the course of
human history very fascinating book um a
little worrisome but it will definitely
change
your it'll change your level of
awareness about like you know media
scripts human beings it's how Med humans
know what to do and if the New York
Times tells you to be mad about
something and you just decide to be mad
about it and you don't know who's
telling you that or why then like that's
not a very enlightened way to go through
life I don't think it's maybe not a very
intellectually honest way if you haven't
really evaluated the opinions that you
hold for yourself and it's hard it's
hard work to do all of that but it's got
to be done or you know you you you don't
feel that hand up inside you but you are
still you are a puppet to some extent if
you haven't done that work
so there's a lot of people who um I
think recognize There's issues and
they're like man this sucks like you
know I want to criticize this thing and
so Bashi has this quote the most
constructive type of criticism is
building an alternative and it feels
like maybe the internet now is getting
to that point where people realize uh we
can take this skill we have of building
things and marry it with the criticism
that we previously lobbed on social
media and like that is that equals
opportunity as like an
yeah I mean there I counted I think I
did a specific read of this book and
counted business ideas I think there's
at least 20 very specific like probably
a paragraph each about things that you
could pick up and go build that exist
with technology today that solves a
problem like this or adjacent to it and
I think I think if I remember correctly
I put that exact quote on like the back
of the book because I want it to be like
I want this whole thing to feel like a
call to action to build don't argue
online build the future like the answer
to
this the answer to everything the best
answer is not just to whine online or
point fingers is to build something and
build a better solution than what we
have today and there's a lot of problems
and a lot of challenges with the media
but these
are solvable and what I Tred to do like
this is not a crypto book but there is a
lot of Illusions to the blockchain in
there and
bology does as good a job as I've ever
heard anyone do of showing sort of what
the world could look like with a crypto
spine and Foundation under it and why
it's so important to have this record
this this technology that can help us
keep a record of Truth and if we can
build an entire sort of media ecosystem
on top of this record of
Truth man does the world change and a
lot of these kind of risks
around people fabricating like outright
lies or intentionally or
unintentionally and pushing the world in
in a the wrong direction or covering
things up or uh making false
claims does really it's it's limited um
and it goes way down and way more people
have an incentive to build and
distribute things around the truth and
he makes a really interesting point in
there you know you could start with like
why does that matter like why does the
truth matter it's all just competing
narratives
anyway and he tells the story of the
USSR and the US um kind of the like cold
war ramp up in production where we were
really having like an economic war
between communism and capitalism and
bology says that the US won because
communism basically requires you to lie
more like you have to make up numbers
for projections you you have to tell
people to do specific things you have to
tell them that things are coming maybe
when they're not and capitalism just
adjusts way faster rewards people to act
on truthful information like what is
what is the actual Supply what is the
actual demand how do we change the
market clearing price how do we
orchestrate these different companies
and these different people most
effectively to produce you know food and
houses and cars and tools that we need
to to take care of our population and
that capitalism just rewards truth in a
more effective an immediate way and that
that is why the US one and if you think
about that scoped out and see Tech see
blockchain as a technology for improving
sort of the feedback loop between the
truth of the fundamental reality and our
ability to interact with it um you know
it's just one more of these huge
variables that goes towards sort of
accelerating the future um there's a
long list of them but it's an important
one and it's one I'm I'm excited to like
keep adding to that list and exploring
all of them and just seeing you know how
Wild can the future get like I'd love to
live to see some cool bu and like
let's So speaking of uh kind of building
this future and you know building the
alternative there's another part of the
book that says startup equals growth if
you don't consciously optimize your
company for growth you will be outgrown
by a competitor who has and whether it
is you know effective accelerationism
whether it is just startups in general
it feels like this growth vers like
degrowth or you know deceleration tends
to be a a Hot Topic right now how do you
think about those two things yeah I
think I mean this is the whole back
third of the book is very tactical
startup founder advice basically um it
it's kind of like zero to one I think in
that it's like a handbook for Founders
like get out there get off the ground
find ideas uh iterate on them sort of
triage your biggest ideas and your best
ideas and then you know go from truly go
from zero to one and scale out from
there um I think you you know this is
not General small business advice or
lifestyle business advice it's very
specifically in the like high-tech
high-scale startup but startup equals
growth I think is PG's thing and not
just growth but growth in a very big
Market um and so another apologies kind
of idioms in that is you know all other
things being equal choose the
opportunity with the bigger market like
that is a that should be a mathematical
rule of startups that pushes you as
you're sort of running the the maze
towards what idea you want to start
start something and grow like hell start
something in a truly enormous Market um
and then figure out how to start really
small and iterate feature by feature
through customers are willing to pay for
feature one customers are willing to pay
for feature two customers are willing to
pay for feature three and minimize the
amount of capital that you need sort of
at each stage as you go along um I'm I
am
really I have been on the
accelerationist sort of train since I
think before we had like the effect of
acceleration is movement um the book
where's my flying car was really my
first like I put the book down and I was
like I am an accelerationist now like I
want I want a next Industrial Revolution
I want it now I will dedicate my life to
making this happen um and it really
actually influenced the ideas that I
selected to go in the anthology of
biology like it informed my curation and
it I had these vague Notions coming out
of that book that bolog
it turns out had incredibly well put
ideas around you know just about
technology being sort of the driving
force of history and about technology
being this incredibly important moral
good that keeps us out of this realm of
scarcity where people start to turn on
each other and things get dark um the
the there's just so there's so many
fascinating things that could be and
could be in the next 10 years or 50
years that could happen in our lifetimes
and it's just a fundamental source of
optimism for me I love looking forward
and I love sort of pushing on that
movement and helping other people who
see a bright future um
and you know this ties into the media
point like I do not know why but there
are a lot of people putting a lot of
other I don't know if they're against
progress against acceleration or if they
just have other priorities that they
think are more important but there's
some
really what seems like really obviously
dumb debates and things happening like
especially in the media and especially
around technology at the moment
um where I the media just like
instinctively attacks technology and in
particular new technology um it makes
sense in this in the course of like they
were attacking social media and the
internet because it was eating into
their ad Revenue right for the last 20
years we've had you know Facebook
Twitter Instagram eating into newspaper
and online ad Revenue but
with something like self-driving cars I
think is like the best example that
we're living through right
now 10 years ago when self-driving cars
were just a concept everyone was so
excited oh my God we're gonna have
self-driving cars hundreds of thousands
of people aren't going to die
senselessly anymore every year from car
accidents it's the leading cause of
tragic death basically in life
especially of young people
um but it's so it's so wild we're so
excited about as a concept now 10 years
ago or 10 years later we have
self-driving cars like they exist I've
seen videos of them on the road I've
ridden in them they are in multiple
cities and all you see in the headlines
is people like oh self-driving car
Causes Chaos in San Francisco it's like
but there were 10,000 fatal accidents
all over the US and fires from internal
combustion cars but you're attacking
electric cars and you're attacking
autonomous cars in every
headline why that that is so so
obviously better for society to have
this thing and fewer people will die and
there will be fewer less suffering and
it uses less resources like can we not
all be on the same team about that and
if we can't be on the same team about
that then like how do we move forward on
all these other things that are actually
potentially much more nuanced and much
more difficult and much more um socially
challenging so it is um I hope that this
book sort of brings people a little
farther along into the
technology is good acceleration is good
like there are beautiful things in our
lives like your life gets better as a
function of the technology in it you
know it's the reason that we are safe
and warm and a temperature that we're
happy with and we have a roof over our
head and that we're all get to eat
delicious things pretty much all year
round like we live in an absolute
unfathomable abundance compared to where
we were 200 years ago where we could be
in 200 more years is absolutely even
more mind-blowingly incredible because
we're on that exponential
curve but we owe it to the Future
generations to not that up and send
them back to the Dark Ages and we you
know it's not a0 percent chance because
we don't all collectively have our
together to be rooting for technology
and excited and adopting new
things the one thing I'll add is um also
the problems are going to multiply so
self-driving car is one of the um one of
the things that just hammered at home
for me when self-driving cars solve car
deaths at some point whether that
happens in two years or 20 years there
will be a crisis the crisis will then be
on organ donation because the largest
component of organ donations come from
car accidents and so you solve one
problem another one pops up right you
gotta go solve that one and so like
there's never a a shortage of problems
even when you kind of eat into the
problem list um which is almost to me
like an even stronger argument of like
you think our problems today are bad
wait till we solve some of these and
then we get our you know the the
problems we have earned oursel and we
better be really really good at
accelerating technology to to be
prepared for that world as well yeah
there's always somebody saying like but
that but if we do that that will cause
this problem and it I think it is a
fundamental tenant of technology and
progress to always believe the next
problem is solvable you know there was
somebody at Kittyhawk when humans took
flight for the first time being like we
got to shut this down like
somebody's going to die uh these things
will never be safe and now like truly
only a few decades later like not a huge
scheme in the huge scheme of things like
we have an incredibly reliable safe
worldwide commercial air infrastructure
like that is absolutely wild and we
should all be incredibly proud of that
we should be doing a ton more things
like that um yeah I think you know the
organ donor example is a great one yeah
yeah let's do some like genetic cloning
grow some organs in some Labs like the
next problem is solvable AI is there's a
ton of debate around Ai and AI safety
and I'm in the camp that's like AI is
not without risk no technology is
without risks but every technology that
I can think of in human history has done
more good than it has bad and I think AI
is going to be the same way and the camp
that I fall into is we Face a ton of
risks a lot of like we're trying to
become multiplanetary we could have a
much more dangerous pandemic at any
point we could have nuclear war we could
have a meteor headed our way like what
if inventing Ai and H like having that
multiplier effect on the capabilities of
humanity is the only way that we can
develop technology to the point where we
can steer away the meteor fight the next
pandemic um there's so many things that
AI helps us do that I think it a net
benefit to humanity it say it could save
us from all these other risks let alone
that it increases the standard of living
for all of us along the way and helps us
support like a much broader more robust
uh more Humane life for billions of
people like that's so that's so
important I understand it takes a little
bit of
a counterintuitive leap to get there and
that everybody's first reaction is like
oh my god oh no change like it's scary
um I might lose my job it's like well do
you like your job like no it sucks it's
like all right well then what are you
worried about like get get a new job the
book is called the anthology of BAGI a
guy to technology truth and building the
future I highly suggest anyone who's not
read it please go uh check it out um
again I read it twice I probably will
end up reading it again many times over
the years so Eric I appreciate taking
the time to uh to put it all together
before I let you go um on on your uh
side gig of scribe while while you are
be a bestselling author over and over
and over again um you now are gonna help
other people uh write books and and uh
kind of get into the author game talk a
little bit about scribe and and what you
guys are trying to do this episode is
brought to you by cal.com what do I I
have in common with Chad Hurley from
YouTube Toby from Shopify and Alexis
from 776 and the co-founder of Reddit we
all use cal.com instead of cly and we
are all early investors as well cal.com
is leading the charge of scheduling
platforms and the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all all of the
benefits of open- source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take keep
back control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your time yeah
dude this is a wild story okay so I in
writing the almanac and noal I had no
idea how to write a book I was just kind
of like collecting nal's ideas and
somewhere along the way I tweeted like
hey I think I have a manuscript for a
book but I don't know how to publish it
and Tucker Max who I'd been reading for
a long time um reached out I was like
hey I'm happy to help like let me know
what I can do and so I got on the phone
with Tucker and he was the founder of
this company scribe and Tucker really
helped me understand the publishing
landscape and sort of walk me through
the options and talk to me about like
what would make this a great book and
what I needed in order to do and I
scribe helped me publish that book The
Almanac Nal was absolutely it was
life-changing to write it was
unbelievably life-changing to publish
like we've now sold over a million
copies this thing's translated into like
languages it precedes me everywhere I go
it's and we've given away another 5
million copies for free probably
everything in my life that has happened
in the last 3 years is because of this
book
um life-changing experience and I had a
tremendously high quality like
incredible experience as an author was
scribe and so I was obvious I was I was
going to work with them again for the
anthology of biology and they did help
me publish this book also and along the
way I started hearing like rumors that
they were having financial trouble um
and what it turned out it had happened
is that Tucker and Zack obon who founded
the company both great dudes had hired a
CEO and sold it to him along the way and
the CEO had brought in his own investors
and didn't really have a board didn't
really have a CFO
like uh made some mistakes like
definitely made some mistakes that the
fundamental model like was very sound he
just got really ere exuberant um and had
a loan and so the bank foreclosed on the
business and they ended up I was like
holy like this company that I rely
on to published my books that I had such
an incredible experience with that I
loved everybody
there like is in great Peril like let me
see if I can save this thing like I want
to keep using them I'm a big believer in
what they do and what they represent in
the publishing industry
so I took him around to some friends who
buy buy companies you know uh I've Got
Friends with long-term holding companies
or small private Equity Funds and um so
I just made some calls and one of them
went under Loi did the diligence was
blown away by the team and I mean scribe
is an incredible position they're the
biggest and the best of these
professional Publishers um they
published 2,000 books including goggin
and TB and some big big name authors and
books that have gone on to sell millions
of copies and they let authors retain
their full creative rights all their
independent decision-making and 100% of
the royalties they're basically
Professional Services instead of saying
like here's an advance but we get all
the control and all the upside on the
book which I think is a really important
thing for you know incredibly important
in an era of creators who already have
their own audiences um explain this
explain this part a little bit more
because I don't think people quite
understand when they hear publishing
they think I get the advance you take
all of the money until some magic number
in the future but basically what people
are doing is they're paying a flat fee
with help in the publishing world
and then they get 100% of the quotequote
profit of the success of their
book yes so and I know that you know
this because I know that you guys have
been through you and your wife have been
through the traditional publishing
machine most people don't realize those
big Publishers they
take 75 to like 90% of all the profits
and they basically get final edit final
decision- making over everything in on
and around the book um if you don't like
your audio book narrator too bad if you
don't like the cover of like the too bad
um they can change the title they can
edit they can do whatever they want and
they basically own that they have a
lease on the copyright for the full
length of the copyright so the authors
that you see who sell a ton of books
often do well but the publisher gets 90%
of that plus and there's an agent in
there also and what scribe
offers is the ability for like it's not
actually that expensive to publish a
book like if you bring a manuscript to
us we will help you get it published at
the exact same level of quality and
professionalism in design in page layout
and proof reading and copy editing
distribution that these traditional
Publishers will and it'll cost you like
$188,000 so if you think your book is
going to be
worth 500,000 a million dollars of the
the full value of that asset over the
course of its whole
life that's a no-brainer like why would
you give up 90% of that for $100,000
Advance um and I think what's happened
you know this a classic like innovators
dilemma like the context has changed
around traditional Publishers but they
haven't updated their model 100 years
ago you had to you needed distribution
into bookstores and the physical
distribution of the infrastructure to
get it or you couldn't sell any books
now 90% of books are sold on Amazon
doesn't matter at all um secondly the
you needed a huge upfront capital
investment to get a print run now most
books are print on demand also don't
need the huge Capital upfront investment
to get your book out there and third you
used to need these connections into
centralized media
to have have a book review or get it in
the newspaper or go on The Late Show and
without that sort of in from the
traditional Publishers and the like New
York media Elite like you couldn't get
the word out about your book so they
were Gatekeepers and they could price
themselves like Gatekeepers the thing
that now there's no gate like anybody
can list a book on Amazon you don't need
upfront Capital because it's print on
demand
and everybody just talks about books and
recommends them to each other on social
media and so it much more of like an
open decentralized meritocracy and so
especially if you already have an
audience and have a dris
message there's no reason to give up 90%
of your upside on your book um and what
we work with authors from the full range
of you almost every author has a
motivation other than maximizing Book
Sales it's either I want impact on my
other business you know we have authors
who just give away copies of their book
but they earn millions of dollars on
their Consulting business and the book
is lead genen for them we have authors
who come in and say I just want to
impact this cause you know I want to
prevent you know gay teen suicide and I
will spend thousands of dollars and
years of my life on that cause and all I
care about is saving if I save five
lives I will I will die happy um and
that's what matters to me no traditional
publisher is going to touch that but you
still want that book to have a really
professional polished feel and you still
want it to be broadly distributed and
you want that author to have the control
to make all the decisions that they need
to make to impact their cause or impact
their business and that's what we do we
give the author maximum flexibility at
the very highest level of quality um
nobody no reader picks up a book Because
of Who the publisher is or what the
imprint is they just know and they feel
the quality and so if we can help
authors publish their book at the very
highest levels of quality and help them
enter that meritocracy then I think a
lot of them are going to have great
outcomes even your goal is very
specifically like big Financial outcome
directly from the book then it's so
important to Own 100% of your royalties
and not have this like big majority
controlling partner who has a huge
portfolio and if your book isn't
crushing isn't going to go isn't going
to go to war for you um you know I think
the books that we see that are breakout
successes are authors with high majority
control they think of themselves as like
the CEO of the book and like we love to
work with people who are the CEO of the
book and they treat their book like a
business they think about it like an
asset and they have a long-term view on
like how we make this thing successful
how does it fit into my other ecosystem
of products um and I mean I think books
are sacred and there's a Prestige around
them and it's it's just so um it is
truly so fun to now get to play that
role for other people that like Tucker
played for me and just be like hey you
got a book this can be an inflection
point for you let's talk about how to
make it happen about how to position it
let's talk about what the best places
are to get it out there and how we can
Market it um so it's a it's a really
really fun thing um and yeah I I just
like I'm so glad um enduring Ventures
stepped in to like buy scribe and save
it and then you know a few a few weeks
after they bought it they called me and
we're like hey uh we need somebody to
run this thing and we think that should
be you um you know you're you're an
author you're a Believer you sold it to
us like you clearly have a feel for this
industry and I was like I do love
working with authors and helping and so
I joined the summer and um it's been
it's been growing again like crazy it's
been super satisfying work um we're
talking to some really big authors and
have some really cool books in
development it's it's a very very fun
gig and I think I think there's gon to
be a huge Next Generation publishing
company that gets built that gets to go
toe-to-toe with these traditionals and I
I hope it's us I um I always judge a
aidea a business and a team based on
initial gut reaction when I see
announcements and when I saw scribe who
I've had the pleasure of going and uh
hanging out with Tucker like you know on
on the property explained the whole
story like everything right um then you
and enduring I was like got it makes
sense home run like it was just
immediately passed the the gut Checker
like the smoke test and I think that
those are usually the best uh
opportunities now obiously there's a lot
of work that's involved you got to
execute correctly and all that stuff but
um yeah it just made a lot of sense when
when you guys announced it so it's it's
pretty cool to see thank you yeah I I
think um I'm really excited to get to
work with like a huge swath of incoming
book writers you know I think I think
there's going to be some really cool
stuff done and I love when people bring
us stuff that's like a little too
extreme or a little too weird for like a
traditional publisher that they don't
want to take a swing on and I'm like
hell yeah like let's go let's let's make
this happen for you fun stuff
absolutely absolutely cool where where
can we send people if they want to uh
learn a little bit more about scribe or
potentially they're thinking about
writing a book and uh and would like to
get in touch with you yeah scrib
media.com um scrib media.com you can
follow us on Twitter but scbe media.com
come do a schedule a consult we've got a
ton of people who are truly Pros um in
this and we'll talk you through all your
options and if we're not a great fit for
you we we know where to send you um but
we just love to brainstorm and help
authors figure things out and uh yeah
you I'm eon.com you can find all my
projects and all my content there if uh
if you want to reach out I'm happy to
like brainstorm through things and I'm
I'm just a huge believer in making
beautiful books and I felt firsthand
what a book can do for people um I know
your house has been going through the
same thing so H hidden genius on
bookshelves
now I appreciate you Pina appreciates
you more than the than you know um I
appreciate you coming on we'll
definitely do this again in the future
thanks for having me let's make it a
tradition